- HEY, JADINKALAGE?
- YEAH, L'CARPETRON?
- CHECK OUT LEOZ.
I WONDER WHAT
HE'S DREAMING ABOUT?
- HE IS PROBABLY DREAMING
ABOUT WHAT WE IS GONNA DO
TO THE TEAM FROM THE WEST.
- I WONDER.
- ♪ T'VARIUSNESS ♪
♪ T-KING FOR SHORT ♪
♪ I'M A BAD MAMMA-JAMMA ♪
♪ AND AN AWFUL SPORT ♪
- ♪ SMOOCHIE-WALLACE ♪
♪ YOU CAN CALL ME TYROIL ♪
♪ RAPPIN' UP RUSHES
LIKE ALUMINUM FOIL ♪
- ♪ MCCRINGLEBERRY ♪
♪ I'M VERY SCARY ♪
♪ IF I GOT THE BALL
YOU BEST BE WARY ♪
- ♪ L'CARPETRON DOOKMARRIOT ♪
♪ I LOVE THE BALL SO MUCH
I WANNA MARRY IT ♪
all: ♪ 'CAUSE THE EASTERN
SCHOOL'S ♪
♪ GONNA BEAT THE FOOLS
FROM THE WEST ♪
- OH, YEAH.
all: ♪ WHERE FOOTBALL'S
CONCERNED ♪
♪ WE GONNA SHOW YOU
THAT WE ARE THE BEST ♪
- ♪ WE ARE THE BEST ♪
- ♪ I'M IBRAHIM MOIZOOS ♪
♪ AND MY RHYMES ARE CLEAN
LIKE MY NAME IS DR. SEUSS ♪
- ♪ PROBINCRUZ III ♪
♪ THEY CALL ME "THE PROBE" ♪
♪ I CAN INTERCEPT BALLS ♪
♪ WITH MY EARLOBE ♪
- ♪ SHOWER-HANDEL ♪
♪ THAT'S MY NAME ♪
♪ POWER CANDLE SOUNDS THE SAME ♪
- ♪ WITH JACKMERIUS ♪
- ♪ D'SQUARIUS ♪
- ♪ AND JAVARISON-LAMAR ♪
- ♪ FLACKAWAXA PLAYS SAX AND ♪
♪ D'MARCUS PLAYS GUITAR ♪
all:
♪ 'CAUSE THE EASTERN SCHOOL'S ♪
♪ GONNA BEAT THE FOOLS
FROM THE WEST ♪
- ♪ OKAY ♪
♪ DON'T YOU KNOW ♪
all:
♪ WHERE FOOTBALL'S CONCERNED ♪
♪ WE GONNA SHOW YOU
THAT WE ARE THE BEST ♪
- ♪ INDEEDY, WE ARE THE BEST ♪
- [gasps]
IT MUST HAVE BEEN
ALL A DREAM.
[gasps]
OR WAS IT?
- OH, IT'S ON.
- ♪ WHAT'S UP, Y'ALL ♪
♪ IT'S JEFFERSPIN ♪
♪ I'M THE BIG LEFT TACKLE ♪
♪ GONNA HELP US WIN ♪
- ♪ X-WING AT ALYSSIUSNESS ♪
♪ I'LL USE MY FORCE
TO GIVE THE EAST DISTRESS ♪
- ♪ ALGERNON-SPLATTER'S
WHERE IT'S AT ♪
♪ RUNNING THROUGH DEFENDERS
AND PADDING MY STATS ♪
- ♪ Y'ALL KNOW ME ♪
♪ I'M WASHINGBEARD ♪
♪ CATCH SO MANY BALLS
IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD ♪
all: ♪ 'CAUSE YOU KNOW WE GONNA
WIN AGAINST THE EAST ♪
- ♪ LISTEN WHAT WE SAID ♪
all: ♪ WE GONNA GET
THE MOST POINTS ♪
♪ AND THEY GONNA GET THE LEAST ♪
- ♪ JUST TRYIN' TO CALM THE
VOICES RUNNING THROUGH MY HEAD ♪
- ♪ BACK IT UP ♪
♪ IT'S HARDUNKACHUD ♪
♪ I HIT THE Q.B. AND MAKE
A NOISE LIKE THUD ♪
- ♪ CAN'T BLOCK ME
AND ALL OF THAT JAZZ ♪
♪ 'CAUSE Y'ALL DON'T WANT NONE
OF THIS OZAMATAZZ ♪
- ♪ THE PLAYER... ♪
- ♪ TJ AJ ♪
- ♪ FORMERLY KNOWN... ♪
- [screeches]
[construction noises]
- ♪ LOUITH ♪
- ♪ AS MOUSECOP ♪
- ♪ AND DONKEY TEETH ♪
- ♪ I'M THE TOUCHDOWN MAN ♪
♪ THAT'S GRUNDLEPLINTH ♪
♪ BUT Y'ALL AIN'T READY ♪
♪ FOR MY MAN DAN SMITH ♪
- ♪ YO YO ♪
♪ SMITH COMMA DANIEL ♪
♪ OTHER KICKERS IN THE LEAGUE
DON'T HOLD A CANDLE ♪
♪ CHEERLEADERS UP ON
MY CHOCOLATE CROTCH ♪
♪ THOSE GODDAMN
BABY COCKER SPANIEL ♪
♪ B.Y.U.
WHY YOU BE ♪
♪ MAD 'CAUSE THE BITCHES
WANNA GET WITH ME ♪
♪ GOT SWISHER SWEETS
AND DUTCHIES ♪
♪ ROLLIN' ON
NO OTHER TEAM CAN TOUCH THESE ♪
♪ HITTIN' FIELD GOALS
BLUNTED ♪
♪ BEEN DRUNK WHEN I PUNTED ♪
♪ BEEN LIKE A HUNDRED TIMES ♪
♪ THAT I ALREADY DONE IT ♪
♪ OH, [bleep] ♪
♪ SEE THESE HATERS
THOUGHT I WAS PLAYIN' ♪
♪ STAYIN' AWAY FROM MY FACES ♪
♪ WITH ALL THE BULL[bleep]
THEY SAYIN' ♪
♪ BUT JUST REMEMBER
WHO YOU TAUNTIN' ♪
♪ WHEN YOU TOSSIN'
THOSE GAUNTLETS ♪
♪ I'M DAN SMITH AND THE WEST IS
GETTIN' ROWDY LIKE MONSTERS ♪
[all cheer]